[Music]
finally tonight
there are people who talk to talk some
even make a living doing it
and i'm generally humored by them the
ones who think they know everything
pontificate on things about which they
have no experience no frame of reference
but still assume presume and fancy
they know it all take a listen
look at what janine pirro this is just
outrageous janine
janine i'm looking at you you should be
ashamed of yourself
she said that these kids are a lower
level of human being
joy behar a perfect example of one who
talks the talk now i just came back from
the southwest border having actually
interviewed people on the front lines
who say that children are being
trafficked by the cartels
and forced into a lower level of human
being
the sheriff in charge of the largest
southwest international border area
in the united states and one of the most
dangerous where the sinaloa cartel
operates cochise county
says that what's happening to these
children is quote
modern day slavery the children
ultimately become slaves
to the cartel consider this
20 percent of the children brought here
have no known family in the united
states
transnational cartels seize upon them
putting them in harm's way and use and
abuse these young children
physically and sexually even keeping
them
under the cartel's thumb once they are
in the united states because they have
no family here
they are then forced to continue to work
for the cartel we're not even taking dna
which for these lost children would help
identify them
to me that's placing innocent
vulnerable children in a deadly
environment
forcing them to be a lower level human
that any reasonable person would
recognize
as abhorrent it is those children i
spoke about on fox
the ones who were being trafficked
abused and brought across the border
who then become slaves to sex
traffickers
i know believe me i know as d.a i
prosecuted cases like these
on behalf of victims many of whom didn't
speak english
and afraid to speak in their native
tongue because the cartels held
families in their home country under the
threat of violence or retribution
i provided translators to help protect
these victims
my mission joy has been protecting
children my whole career
i started one of the first child abuse
units in the nation
check your favorite paper the new york
times
when child abuse was considered a social
issue and not a crime
i didn't talk about it i did it i fought
the system and made it happen
to me a child chained to a radiator is
not a social problem
a child too young to identify sexual
parts of her body being abused
is entitled to more than mediation she
is entitled to justice
i also started one of the first domestic
violence units in the nation
fighting to protect battered women and
the children forced to live with the
violence
some of whom were murdered in that same
violent home
i didn't just talk to talk joy about
children being raped scalded or beaten
to death
i did something about it i spent my time
in emergency rooms with victims
in hospital rooms with children and in
morgues
in heartbreaking silence and you
want to lecture me you want to talk
about escaping violence
people are escaping violence they're
escaping drugs
they're escaping poverty and with
climate change
on the horizon i think it's just going
to get worse
escaping violence that's the point joy
even the sheriff said it was modern day
slavery
because the cartels hold on to these
children
you think they're escaping drugs they're
becoming mules for the cartels
for 30 years i help people escape
violence
and i punished those who committed that
violence i didn't talk about it
i didn't put myself on a chair in front
of a camera
and yap about something i fought i
prosecuted i convicted
i sentenced and when the laws weren't
strong enough i fought to change the
laws
i created task forces and provided
shelters
and safe havens connecting with churches
and social services
and mental health professionals so don't
you ever
accuse me because unlike you i don't
just
talk the talk i have actually walked the
walk
i did something i did something
i actually did something so instead of
sitting on your
butt with your friends pontificating get
down to the border
go into a courtroom a victim center
family court
a shelter volunteer have the courage to
step
off your comedy club stage and do
something that matters
that makes a difference and yeah joy
i'm talking to you
and that's my closing